quick questions the first one is not
many stars on Disney and Nickelodeon end
up translating into films like this so
first how has that been and lastly what
was it like to win this in front of the
Presleys and having their big support we
saw on the camera they were so happy for
you all right well
it's your first question
um
you know I I remember going to so many
auditions and never booking anything and
I just feel so grateful right now I am
I uh I'm still coming back from sort of
blacking out I um
to be in that room full of all these
people that I've admired so much and it
just means so much to me
um and then in front of the presides who
have now welcomed me into their family
in such a beautiful way and I just feel
so endlessly grateful to them that they
provided this space for me to somehow
try to capture the essence of this man
that they that means so much to them and
that they love so much you know
thank you thank you
hey how are you
mastered The Voice so well
still
tell you that are you catching yourself
constantly you know that is your voice
now
yeah I don't even think about it I I uh
you know I don't think I sound like him
still but I I guess I must because I
hear it a lot um I think you know I
often liken it to when somebody lives in
another country for a long time and I
had three years where that was my only
focus in life so I'm sure that there's
just pieces of my DNA that will always
be linked in that way
Austin congratulations yeah hey what
advice did you get from Elvis's family
we were perfect for the role
it was less advice and more more feeling
of blessing you know which which meant
so much to me
thank you
I love this mic on a stick like that I
haven't seen that before
all right well thank you guys this was
painless
thank you
thank you guys thank you
[Music]